when the attorney general swella
braverman announced that she was
expecting her
second child a curious problem emerged
under current laws she would have to
resign to take time off to have a child
now unlike most workplaces in this
country
her position doesn't come with maternity
leave
a special bill has been drawn up to try
and fix the outdated laws
uh very pleased to say uh the women's
rights activist dr helen
helen pankers which he leads the
centenary action group which campaigns
for women's representation and
participation in politics
and she joins us on the programme helen
great to have you on and
and no prizes for any of our viewers who
recognize that very famous
surname of yours but but let's perhaps
start with with the 21st century
or indeed aspects of the 19th century
that still appear to be plaguing the
house of commons what do you make of the
the current rules around maternity
well ridiculous arcane i mean whatever
critical term you could be using i mean
it's great
that the government is introducing this
bill the problem is that it's only
resolving the problem for some people so
for the secretary of state and shadow
cabinet
ministers what we need is
a systematic uniform automatic
right for paternity adoption
maternity leave all of that so that
whole
hr system that ensures equality
and that ensures that all mps can do
their job
and have cover some systems some
resources
when they are away on leave
i i just wonder why you feel there has
perhaps been this
reticence to deal with a problem that
frankly should have been obvious
to anyone with eyes i mean i remember
very well
at the eruptions that went on and in
private
you know when it was proposed that one
of the bars get changed into a crash
you know it does feel like parliament
sometimes is languishing
you know back in the days of your great
grandmother
yeah it does take us back centuries
really doesn't it
it's such a pity i mean you know we want
to have more
uh it we want citizens and mps to be
more in touch with each other and
understand the issues that are
um that are in society and we want to
increase the percentage of
women in parliament uh you know
currently it's what it's
34 and in terms of counsellors it's 35
so we we want to get that equality and
we want more diversity so
parliament to also represent all the
diversity bame issues of disability
for it to be a place where anybody can
thrive
and within this coalition that i'm
involved in the centenary action group
we are campaigning to look at and
address the barriers but also
to get more people that come up and say
they want to become
mps they want to become counsellors and
when they see
that ludicrous um
i mean i'm i'm losing the words but the
system the hr system
that we have is just not fit for purpose
it's not fit for the 21st
century and we have this opportunity
right now
and it you know it's sad in a way that
it took
one of their own it took a uh secretary
of state to
be pregnant for the governments to now
want to rush through a
uh a policy and what we need to make
sure is that this policy isn't just for
some
that actually it addresses that the
absolute need
for you know structural systems that
ensure that
any uh mp can work
effectively when they are pregnant and
they need to take leave
that their constituencies are well
served that there's a good system
that ensures that a citizen has a system
that continues and that is represented
and that's what mps are calling for
that's what we need to ensure happens
yeah i mean i mean i suppose the kind of
the concomitant effect of there having
been no kind of maternity cover is that
you know
parliamentarians have generally tended
not to have children now if that were to
change in significant numbers
we would need to see some tinkering with
the system wouldn't we i mean
the job of an mp is not quite the same
as any other role
when an mp is offer an extended period
you need someone in there with the same
level of authority to deal with
constituents
to deal with votes in the house and and
so on
exactly and it's about having a system
because otherwise what happens
is for whatever reason uh you know
a father who wants to take time off uh
there's this guilt that and it's not uh
it's not
best practice and we know that if you
have a system it's
known it's transparent then people will
use it
they'll be able to work effectively what
we have now
is a parliament where women cannot work
effectively
when they are pregnant when they need to
take leave fathers can't do so either
either
when there's issues of sickness as well
there's no transparent automatic system
um so it ends up being a little bit a
rule for one and not the other and
that's just really not what we need it
it's just not effective it's not
efficient
it's not equitable dr helen pankas great
to have you on the program this morning
really enjoyed talking to you thanks for
being here
thank you